live local now and we start right now at
noon with that child on a bike hit by a
pickup truck thanks for making us part
of your day everybody i'm david charns
right now metro police are investigating
at rainbow right near cheyenne and smoke
ranch 8 news is victoria saha live there
and victoria what have you learned
the scene here cleared about 30 minutes
ago and traffic is now allowed back
through the road here was closed for
more than four hours i'm going to show
you this road here you can see the
markings that police left for their
investigation and right over here my
photog is going to zoom in this is where
the bike was
the accident happened just before 7 this
morning right at rainbow and peak drive
a pickup truck hit a child on a bike no
word yet on the condition of the child
but fatal investigators were called out
here metro police tell me in an incident
where there are critical injuries or
death the fatal detail is called out at
the time of the crash a city bus was
stopped and a man who was inside says he
saw what happened he thinks the child
was a boy possibly around 12 years old
he didn't care about the bicycle we are
winners
we saw the hold and the whole thing did
and
it didn't look good the other day i was
riding i saw young
those the crossing guards were here and
i i saw a young boy on a bike and they
stopped the traffic and the kid made it
across safely
i also want to add that this is a school
zone and an elementary school is nearby
that man you just heard from carlos
rutado lives in the area and just rode
his bike through this route right before
the incident he says there are crossing
guards here before and after school
hours but when the crash happened there
weren't any crossing guards here
reporting live victoria saha 8 news now